i've watched buzzfeed medical videos
i've been in buzzfeed medical videos but
today i'm actually reacting to buzzfeed
medical videos let's give a huge thank
you to my longtime sponsor thrive market
and while i watch these i'm going to be
doing a little
bee seaweed snack
i played never have i ever with dr mama
jones never have i ever gotten a really
bad grade on something in medical school
who hasn't i mean med school is tough
like some of the subjects just
absolutely beat you down i don't know
why biochemistry really stopped me the
most
never have i ever pulled an all-nighter
come on
who hasn't pulled an all-nighter in med
school if any of them say they have not
i don't buy it
i don't believe in all nighter she's
never
pulled an all-nighter that's really
impressive i will go to bed at like
10 30 every night look she knows herself
that's impressive that's a good thing
the fact that she's
organized enough to prevent that from
being a problem amazing never have i
ever messed up when learning or trying
to do something
and that's what learning is about even
if you read about doing something in
practice
it's a completely different story like
you learn on a mannequin you go to see a
patient and then you realize they're a
human not a mannequin and they have
their own intricacies and anatomic
anomalies
it gets hard first we were practicing
intubation which is basically
you know putting a tube in someone's
mouth so they can breathe if they can't
breathe on their own
and it was mannequins obviously but the
very first thing the doctor said was
don't go like this or else you're gonna
break their teeth and the actual
mannequins
have a design in them so if you are
pulling like that it makes like a huge
crunch noise to scare you and teach you
that you could be hurting their teeth
never have i ever fallen asleep in class
i remember
this is such a funny story to tell when
i was in undergrad the professor had a
very strict rule
if you were going to fall asleep in the
classroom you had to sit in the back row
and rest your head against the wall so
it looks like you're paying attention
that was a legit rule and i kind of
thought like he was being maybe
sarcastic
or something so one night where i didn't
get good sleep i'm in the second
telestroke and i kind of fell asleep on
my arm he kicked me out of the class and
at the end of that class there was a
quiz that i then got a zero on
i really thought he was kidding i am not
a doctor
by the way doctors aren't also good at
pronouncing these medical terms and sam
already has told me that i have to
pronounce these so be prepared for some
bad pronunciation english is my second
language
bor bergami
bourbon this is actually just like the
sound your stomach makes so like this
isn't that exciting
[Music]
borborygmy four burgundy barbary
i feel like i have something to do with
the butt it's an adhd problem i'm born
with an extra
of something like you got a bad butt why
is everyone talking about butts
colleedo oh this is good colito co
colitocolithiasis i've actually
pronounced this term
in residency because i couldn't
pronounce it colleeto colithiasis
that's how i i don't even need to look
at it because it was so hard for me to
pronounce i actually practiced reciting
this because this means you have a
gallstone
in the common bile duct call it daca
that guy's my favorite and colossians
spondylitis this is an easy one thank
you losing spanish spandau lettuce
and kill losing spontaliditis
i like that they call it ankle losing
temporoperitalis but like i think this
is just like a headache
you have to take it latin so temporo
means your temples
parietal is the sides all right tell us
i don't know what this is
temporopariatalis oh it is a scalp
muscle
sphygmomanometer dilshada
couldn't get this spig nominometer spig
nominometer it's a sphingomonometer is
that how you say it
i thought it was this big nominometer
we'll be back to the content just a
second but let me tell you about thrive
marketing it's an online marketplace
where you can buy
thousands of products for your home for
your pets for your groceries it's where
i love to do my shopping because i
simply don't have the time to go out to
the store and buy all these products
i can have them shipped directly to my
door the best part is
you're gonna be saving money eating
healthy living a healthy lifestyle it
can get quite expensive but by shopping
on thrive market
members on average save 32 dollars per
order on top of it they make it super
easy to browse their website
just type in the diet that you follow
the ethics that you have
keto paleo gluten free vegan it's all
right there on their website and all of
this is not just good for you
it's also safe for the environment
because they have carbon neutral
shipping
and zero waste warehouses they have
multiple membership options for you to
choose from one month to 12 months for
me the 12 month package at five bucks a
month really seems to be the most
reasonable
all you have to do to sign up now is
visit thrivemarket.com
dr mike link down below and you can get
25
off your first order and a free gift
definitely do it now
if you're gonna be buying groceries and
products for your home anyway might as
well save some money
what's the craziest thing you've seen in
the er a guy with
like the thing i use for guacamole i
guess to like grind it i know what the
thing's called
uh he put that up his rectum i feel like
we did like a whole reddit thing of
people putting weird things into their
bodies mom and dr jones on the channel
said something similar the things that
come along with gynecology are endless
anything you can imagine has probably
happened what's the worst smell you've
experienced
i don't know if you want to hear this an
infected gangrenous
wound by far the worst has an incident
ever freaked you out there was a guy
that came in one time
and i unwrapped his foot and there was
maggots all over his foot and it was my
job
lucky me to go and clean up the maggots
and the maggots pretty much ate like
down to the bone well the maggots
usually
eat dead tissue they're not feeding on
live tissue so that means there's some
kind of gangrene already setting in
there how often do you have to look up a
diagnosis
every day i mean things are changing all
the time you
see a lot of the same things all the
time and then
like once in a blue moon you'll get uh
you'll get something that like
you don't know at all i mean that's part
of medicine you just can't know
everything so yeah you're gonna look
stuff up when you look stuff up you
become more comfortable with dealing
with the unknown and that's what makes
medicine fun it's like an ever
learning field
do you still check web web and md when
you don't feel well
absolutely first of all everyone still
checks webmd even when you become a
doctor maybe you shift over to medscape
but little did you know webmd and
medscape are the same company do you
rely on coffee to keep you going
now yes med school no every single day
there's a schedule too it's like for
three months
coffee and then two week break so that
it works again that's a true doctor he's
like
cycling his caffeine intake to make sure
he's getting the maximum benefit from it
have you ever successfully diagnosed
yourself with something
that's classic med school 101. you learn
a condition you think you have the
condition you learn a condition that
occurs in
one per million people that comes with a
headache
you have a headache you say you have
this condition it's just normal it's
part of the process no
but i have successfully misdiagnosed
myself with a bunch of things what was
your least favorite part of medical
school step one
step one step one that's the first
boards that you take
uh like the licensing exam oh you have
to know so
much information so much of it being
pretty
practically speaking useless oh man that
that was tough because that decides
a lot of times where you end up in terms
of your residency so like
is it true that a lot of med students
experiment with drugs caffeine
all the time caffeine yeah i wouldn't
say experiment
i feel like there's more to that story
right from the ocean dolphin and turtle
safe i'm not joking either
[Music]
yeah tea with honey manuka honey green
tea combo
a little lemon with a vitamin c kick
yummy
no no no get the apple cider vinegar out
of here
no it doesn't stop that stop that
nonsense right now
the honey actually works quite well for
cough the american academy of
pediatricians
actually recommends this as part of
their growing body of evidence that
honey can work as well
or better than some over-the-counter
cough suppressants you have to make sure
not to give honey
to kids younger than the age of two
[Music]
this is just extra you do not need to do
this for cough suppression
just let it cough like if you have
phlegm in your lungs and you're trying
to get it out let your body get it out
this is a good thing
[Music]
drinking lots of fluids or a decent
amount of fluids when you're sick
and flemy is really good because it
actually thins the mucus and you're able
to clear it easier
oh come on this is like a commercial for
almonds this is definitely sponsored
that's like saying oh
your head hurts take a magnesium tablet
come on
i mean i just prefer going out and
shelling out the five bucks or so for
like the sailing nasal spray that's
really good because it does clear out
your sinuses you could just like spit it
back out in fact it's also really good
for allergies as well so
yeah i'm for it i just don't know like
this technique specifically
never do this you're gonna wake up with
athlete's foot because your foot has
been soaked in water it's all gonna be
all shriveled up
we don't live in the 1800s anymore like
you just don't need to do this anymore
it's ridiculous
[Music]
the reason you're having a fever is to
actually improve your body's chances to
fight off whatever bug is
causing you problems so putting on cold
socks is not the solution i would never
recommend this
check out here for a playlist of my
craziest medical stories from the
hospital and as always
huge thank you to thrive market for
sponsoring this video don't forget to
sign up down below to get your 25
off your first order and a free gift as
always stay happy and healthy
you